madame la Première ministre dimanche
dernier ce sont plus de 180000 personnes
qui ont défilé dans les rues de 70
villes partout en France qui ont marché
pour la République contre
l'antisémitisme avec le président du
Sénat je veux saluer votre appel madame
la
Présidente
ces marches ont été pour reprendre les
mots du président de la République dans
sa lettre au français un motif
d'espérance ce soulèvement de la nation
et celui de tout un peuple face à la
haine antisémite car l'antisémitisme ce
n'est pas qu'un chiffre horrible que
l'on égraine 1518 actes rien qu'en un
mois ce sont des Françaises et des
Français
comme vous comme moi comme vous comme
vous qui vivent dans la terreur du fait
de la leur confession c'est Max 20 ans
qui en rentrant l'université n'est cassé
parce qu'il est juif c'est Alain qui
porte une kipa et sur qui l'on crache le
genou à terre c'est Samuel qui depuis 30
ans n'est plus allé dans son
université médecine après avoir reçu des
insultes et des coups ou Sarah dont le
fils de 8 ans mis des couches la nuit
par peur d'aller à l'école je tiens
aujourd'hui à remercier nos policiers
nos militaires qui chaque jour
s'assurent de leur
sécurité mais aucun citoyen français ne
devrait avoir à vivre cela car la haine
des Juifs c'est le signe du délitement
de notre République tout comme les fauné
de l'antisémitisme que sont
l'antisionisme et le négationisme
défendu sur certains de ces banes
madame la Première ministre comment
mettre un terme à cette dangereuse
recrudescence de l'antisémitisme dans
notre pays je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président la parole
est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Sylvain
Maillard depuis le 7 octobre et
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas contre
Israël nous assistons une augmentation
sans précédent des actes antisémites
dans notre pays en un mois ce sont plus
de 1500 actes qui ont été constatés
c'est plus que sur une année une année
entière les Français de confession juiv
vivent dans l'angoisse c'est grave c'est
inadmissible dans la République où
personne ne doit être inquiété en raison
de ses
croyances monsieur le président maard
face à ces actes il y a d'abord notre
action résolue nous avons passé des
consignes de vigilance extrême au préfet
nos forces de l'ordre les militaires de
l'opération sentinelle sont mobilisés
pour assurer la sécurité des lieux
sensibles en particulier les les lieux
de culte ou les écoles nous avons
également demandé la plus grande fermeté
au parquet des enquêtes sont lancées des
condamnations sont prononcées jusqu'à 18
mois dans C
cas mais monsieur le Président Maillard
vous avez raison de le dire face à
l'antisémitisme une réaction unanime et
sans ambigué est
indispensable lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est l'affaire de tous
s'en prendre à une personne parce
qu'elle est juive c'est s'en prendre à
la République notre devoir c'est de
lutter contre toutes les
haines monsieur le Président Maillard
dimanche à l'initiative de la présidente
Bron pivé pardon que je tiens à saluer
et à celle du président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher la France a été au rendez-vous
pour dire non à l'antisémitisme et pour
défendre avec force les valeurs de la
République je ne reviendrai pas sur ceux
qui croient pouvoir faire oublier d'où
ils viennent je ne reviendrai pas non
plus sur l'attitude de ceux qui refuse
de marcher contre l'antisémitisme et ont
tenté de salir cette marche à coup de
mensonge
indigne je n'ai pas besoin d'en dire
plus car les Français leur ont répondu
ils ont répondu en marchant très
nombreux contre toutes les haines ils
ont répondu dans l'unité au-delà des
opinions et des croyances ils ont
répondu avec dignité clarté et dans le
rassemblement ensemble nous l'avons
affirmé nous combattrons l'antisémitisme
jusqu'au bout la haine n'a pas sa place
dans la République je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre